the next time you jump in your swimming
pool you're going to think
twice in water we become pre really
[Music]
quickly everyone's had that feeling of
like what's in the pool especially at
night what is it exactly you feel
something swim past your leg it's
like oh my God I don't like thinking
about those things can you hear me our
ambition was to ruin the swimming pool
forever I want to
end this is such a brilliant concept
anything could be beneath you I was so
scared yeah I suppose it is scary I
don't know if I'm going to be able to
watch
it there's something
lurking the hell was that it's not a
safe
environment it's so much fun don't swim
alone we all fall asleep where do we go